ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคือเนียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนเย้
โอเคกลับมาพบกับครูฟ้าแล้วก็คือเรียมนะคะ
ในวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์ 4 นะกินเอ้อ 4 ค่ะวัน
นี้เราเจอกันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10
น้ำ 10 เดือนอะไรเอ่ยเดือน
สิงหาคมใช่แล้วให้คุณเรียนเขียนอยู่เหรอ
คะเดี๋ยวว่ายังค่ะไม่ได้เหยี่ยวๆๆอะไรก็
เขียนแล้วหรอตอนนี้ว่ามันไม่คิด
ขึ้นมานึกว่าคุณลืม
ไม่เป็นไรบีนา 4 นะนาฟังหน่อยแล้วเนอะ
แล้วจะรู้แล้วมั้ย
New ก็แบบกำลังสับสนอยู่ว่า Inter  Media
บี kinemaster ได้เขียนหรือไม่เขียนนี้
อ่ะณโรงเรียนน่าจะฟังแล้วก็วันนี้วันพุธ
นะคะมันพุธที่ 10 สิงหาคมมือถือสิงหาคม
เขียนสักหน่อยก็ดี
บีผชอะไรคะทุกปีพ.ศ
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะโอเคตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วคะคือป่าตอนนี้เวลา 14:00 น
กิน Edge  11 ไอ
พีเอ็มโอเคยิ่งถ้าใช่เพิ่งเพียงเร็วมาก
เลยใช่ค่ะ
อันอ่อค่ะโอเคเลยเข้าใจนะคะวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าก็มีเรื่องมาเล่าให้นักเรียนแล้วก็
หาเล่าให้ครูเรียมฟังด้วยหาไม่
เป็นอะไรค่ะครูป่าเป็น
เรื่องหรือเปล่าเรื่องของฟ้าหรอไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ใช่เรื่องของกูพานั้นว่าเรื่องเนี้ย
เป็นเรื่องของเจ้าชายค่ะ
เรียนเคยเห็นชายไหมแล้วชายช่วยงานที่แบบ
ต้องมีมงกุฏอยู่แล้วใช่ไหมถ่ายชายที่ต้อง
มีมงกุฏนะคะเจ้าชาย
สายอะไรอ่ะมีรสอะไรบ้างลองเสริมเจ้าชายดู
เฮ้ย
ผู้ชายส่วนใหญ่แต่งตัวเหยี่ยวโอ้โหสว่าง
ไม่ไหวนะฟันลดแสงหน่อยนึง
หายอ้าๆใช่ไหมอ่านี่แหละเจ้าชายซึ่ง
เรื่องอยู่กับเขาจะเอามาเล่าเนี่ยเป็น
เรื่องของเจ้าชายหักมาเรียนเจ้าชายที่
ประเทศไทยหรือเปล่าคะคิดว่าน่าจะไม่ใช่
ประเทศไทยนะคะว่าว่าเรื่องนี้เนี่ยเป็น
ที่ยุโรปและกันอยู่
ทำไมอ่ะได้ไหมนี่ว่ายุโรปหรอฟ้ารู้ได้ยัง
ไงเพราะว่าเรื่องที่อยู่ก็เอามาเล่าเนี่ย
คนเขียนเขาเป็น
ใน Thailand มั้งว่าจำไม่ผิดนะน่าจะคน
เขียนน้องเขียน Sorry นี้ขึ้นมาเป็นนิด
นั่นแหละนั่นแหละแอนไหมไม่ได้จ่ายอยู่ใช่
ไหมไม่ชัวร์ค่ะน้องเมียนะเดิมเกิดเราได้
ยินชื่อเจ้าชายเราก็น่าจะรู้นะว่าเป็น
เจ้าชายของไทยหรือเปล่าหรือว่าเป็นเจ้า
ชายทางแบบต่างประเทศ
ประเทศทัวร์อ้าไม่ใช่ไทยว่าอื่นนั่นแหละ
ไม่ใช่เรื่องจริงค่ะคุณเรียมไม่ใช่เรื่อง
จริงนะคะเป็นนิทานเหมือนเดิมค่ะนักเรียน
นิทานกริมม์เนาะนิทานกริมม์น้ำซึ่งเรื่อง
นี้เนี่ยเป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับเจ้าชายแต่
ไม่ใช่เจ้าชาย 1 คน
ก็ชาย 2 คนเหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะคะเรียงไม่ใช่
เจ้าชายมีคนสามคนไม่ใช่ยังไม่ใช่สามคน
ไม่อ่ะสามคนนี้ก็เยอะแล้วนะฮะฟ้าเจ้าชาย
12 คนค่ะ
ทำไมเราต้องพี่เจ้าชายเยอะขนาดนั้นใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่าพระราชามีรูปเยอะนะคะก็ต้องบอก
ก่อนว่าอ่าเป็นเมืองเมืองนึงเนาะเมืองก็
คือมันจะเป็นเมืองเนี่ยก็จะมีบ้านบ้านๆ
ใช่ไหมมีบ้านแล้วก็มีคนอยู่ในเมืองนะคะ
ซึ่งในเมืองเนี่ยมีคนแล้วก็ต้องมีพระราชา
ใช่มั้ยให้พระราชาเนี่ยก็คอยดูแลคนหนึ่ง
คอยดูแลเมืองดูแลคนดูแลเมืองนะคะเป็นพระ
ราชา
มีพระราชาพระราชาเนี่ยเป็นผู้ชายนะคะนัก
เรียนมีพระราชาแล้วก็ต้องมีพระราชินีสุด
ท้ายราชินีนกเป็นผู้หญิงใจทำด้วยเตรียมก็
เป็นผู้หญิงครูฟ้าก็เป็นผู้หญิงเราสองคน
ก็เลยเป็นพระราชินีได้เหรอคะ
ไม่ได้นะคะนี่ไม่ใช่ Math  Magic อะไรคะ
เนี่ยก็คือพระราชินีนะคะก็จะเป็นผู้หญิง
ฮือแล้วพระราชากับพระราชินีนะก็มีลูกด้วย
กันมีลูก
เป็นเจ้าชายก็คือเป็นผู้ชายทั้งหมดถ้ามี
ลูกเป็นผู้ชายแล้วก็เรียกว่าเจ้าชาย
ถ้ามีรูปเป็นมีลูกเป็นผู้หญิงเราก็เรียก
ว่าเจ้าหญิง
และๆแต่พระราชากับพระราชินีเนี่ยมีลูก
เป็นผู้ชายทั้งหมดเลย 12 คนอ๋อก่อนก็เลย
พื้นที่ค่ะก็แบบมีความพอดีมีลูกชายทั้ง 12
คนใช้ก็เหมือนจะมีความสุขนะทุกคนก็โอ้วมี
ลูกติด 2 คนคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็น่าจะโอเคใช่
ไหมแต่
พระราชินีเนี่ยเกาะท้อง
เอาล่ะท้องคนที่ 13 ใช่ค่ะครูเรียมท้องคน
ที่ 13
ก็ก็มีความสุขในคะมีลูกเพิ่มมาอีก 1 คนไง
ถ้าไม่มีลูกเยอะจังนะคะๆแต่พระราชาเดี๋ยว
บอกว่า
ถ้าลูกคนที่ 13 เป็นผู้ชาย
ก็โอเคไม่เป็นไรโอเคเราก็แฮปปี้ดีมีความ
สุขแต่แต่ถ้าลูกคนที่ 13 เป็นผู้หญิง
พระราชาจัก 5 ให้ทำอะไร 12 คนค่ะคือ
เครื่องอะไรใช่ไหมทำไมล่ะทำไมพระราชาต้อง
ฆ่าลูกชาย 12 คนด้วย
ใช่ไม่เข้าใจเตรียมไม่เข้าใจเฮ้อจะมีลูก
ทำไมเราจะมีรู้ทำไมใช่ไหมครับราชาบอกว่า
อยากให้ลูกสาวเนี่ยได้ทุกอย่างได้บ้านได้
เมืองได้เงินให้ลูกสาวหมดเลยให้เจ้าหญิง
หมดเลยก็เลยต้องฆ่าลูกชาย 12 คนก็หรือว่า
เขาไม่อยากได้ลูกชายตั้งแต่แรกซึ่งกูก็
คิดว่าเขาอาจจะไม่อยากได้ลูกชายเอออาจจะ
อยากได้รูปแบบนี้หนูก็เลยแบบมีลูกมา
เรื่อยๆเพื่อจะแบบนึงอยากได้ลูกสาวขอให้
ได้ลูกสาวสักทีอะไรบ้างมาในใช้คิดว่าน่า
จะเป็นอย่างนั้นนะคะคุณแม่เนี่ยพระราชินี
อะเนาะขอพระราชินีฟังพระราชาพูดอะไรชนิด
รู้สึกอย่าเสียใจ
เสียใจร้องไห้เพราะว่ารักลูกไงเนาะๆนี่คน
เป็นแม่ก็รักลูกคนราชินีก็เลยคิดทำยังไง
ดีก็นั่งร้องไห้ทุกวันร้องไห้ร้องไห้ร้อง
ไห้จนมีอยู่ 1 วัน
เจ้าชายเบญจมินทร์มีเจ้าชายชื่อ
เบญจมินทร์
เป็นเจ้าชายคนที่ที่ 12 ก็คือเป็นก็ใช้คน
เล็กที่สุดเลยเป็นน้องนะคนเล็กเลย 22 ใช้
เป็นจะมีในก็เดินมาแล้วก็เห็นคุณแม่ร้อง
ไห้มากๆ
สุดท้ายเป็นจะบินก็เลยถามแม่ว่าแม่ร้อง
ไห้ทำไมเป็นอะไรเราแม่บอกไหมคะว่าเกิด
อะไรขึ้นแม่ก็บอกนะแม่ก็บอกว่าแม่เนี่ย
ไม่มีความสุขเลยแม่ก็เพราะแม่ไม่มีความ
สุขก็คือมีความทุกข์นักเรียนความสุขเวลา
มีความสุขก็จะยิ้มให้คะแล้วเวลามีความ
ทุกข์เนี่ยมึงทีเราก็ร้องให้มันตรงข้าม
กันเนาะแม่กับพ่อแม่มีความทุกข์มากแต่แม่
ไม่อยากบอกมึงจะมี
ชัยเบญจมินก็บอกว่าแบบโธ่แม่แม่อยากรู้
แม่บอกหน่อยบอกหน่อยบอกได้ไหมทำไมแม่ต้อง
ร้องไห้จะชายเบญจมินทร์ก็ถามถามถามถามจน
คุณแม่ก็อ่ะแม่บอกก็ได้
อะไรบอกก็ชายมันจะมินว่าถ้าเกิด
ลูกที่แม่หน่อยกำลังท้องนะพระราชินีท้อง
อยู่เนาะถ้าเกิดได้ลูกสาวลูกๆทั้ง 12 คน
จะตาย
หน้าแม่ก็เล่าให้เจ้าชายอ.เบญจมินฟังกู
แล้วชายเบญจมินทร์ตกใจไหมคะจะใช้เป็นจะมี
ก็ตกใจค่ะเดี๋ยวจะใช้เบญจมินทร์ก็ได้คิด
แล้วก็บอกแม่ว่าแม่อย่าร้องไห้อย่าร้อง
ไห้ไม่ต้องร้องไห้
ลูกเนี่ยจะพาพี่ชายนี้ไปนะคะต้องนี้นี่ๆ
หาพี่ชายหนีออกไปเพราะฉะนั้นแม่ไม่ต้อง
ร้องไห้
เราแม่อยากให้ลูกชายทั้ง 12 คนเนี่ยหนี
ออกไปเหรอคะครูป่าใช่ฮะอ่าแม่หรือว่าพระ
ราชินีเนี่ยเพราะพระราชินีฟังชาย
เบญจมินทร์พระราชินีก็เลยอ่ะงั้นให้ลูกๆ
12 คนหนีดีกว่าดีกว่าตายใช่ไหมหนีดีกว่า
นะคะถ้าชิ้นนี้ก็เลยบอกว่าถ้าอย่างนั้น
ให้เจ้าชายทั้ง 12 คนเนี่ยหนีเข้าไปในป่า
นี้เฮ้ออยู่ในป่ามันต้องมีต้นไม้เยอะใช่
ไหมๆเองนาไม่ต้องมาเยอะๆตลาดมีเสือมีงูใน
ป่าได้เราเรียกป่านักเรียนที่ที่มีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ต้นไม้แม่ก็บอกว่าบอกเบญจะมีนะ
เบญจมินทร์ลูกหนีเข้าไปในป่ากับพี่ชายนะ
แล้วก็ปีนต้นไม้ขึ้นไป
แล้วก็คอยดู
ดูดูใช่ไหมคะดูอะไรคะคุณแม่เนี่ยจะมีธง
หรือเปล่าดูเอ๊ะไกลเห็นคุณแม่เหรอดูใกล้ๆ
ไม่เห็นค่ะครูเรียงแต่ว่า
เนี่ย
ธงอะไรขนาดนี้คงประเทศไทย
อันนี้ธงอ่ะนี่อันนี้คือธง
พงสีแดงด้วยเห็นไหมส่งเสียงคุณแม่บอกว่า
แค่นี้อยู่บนต้นไม้แล้วก็คอยดูนะคะถ้า
เกิดมีธงสีก็แทงขึ้นแปลว่าได้ลูกสาว
เรื่องนอนแล้วกดได้ลูกชายล่ะได้ลูกชายก็
จะมีธงสีขาวขึ้นค่ะเป็นผงสีขาวมึงนั่น
แหละแปลว่าได้ลูกชาย
นั้นทั้ง 12 คนก็จะได้กลับมาใช่ไหมคะถ้า
ได้ชายและลูกชาย 12 คนก็จะกลับมาหนึ่งไม่
ต้องตายนั่นแหละแม่ก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคงั้น
ลูกก็หนีไปนะเข้าเป็นในป่านะคะเบญจมินทร์
ก็เลยพาพี่ชายเนี่ย 11 คนรวมถึง
เบญจมินทร์เป็น 12 คนนะคะเข้าไปในป่าแล้ว
ก็ปีนต้นไม้เพื่อที่จะดูว่าเพลิงธงสีอะไร
อาร์มเรารออยู่นานไหมคะครูฟ้าก็นานนะคะ
ครูเรียมก็รอหลายวันเลยกว่าที่คุณแม่
เนี่ยจะคลอดใช่ไหม
รอดเด็กก็มานั่นแหละอัตราซาวอะไรนี้หรอ
อุ๊ยน่าจะไม่มีนะอันนี้น่าจะเมื่อก่อน
300 ปี 400 ปีนะจะได้ไปแอบซอร์แอบดูงง
อันเตอร์ซาวไหร่ลูกสาวใช่ซึ่งเป็นจะมี
เนี่ยก็ปีนขึ้นไปบนต้นไม้แล้วก็เห็นว่า
พี่วังวังก็คือบ้านเนาะแต่ว่าถ้าเป็นครู
ฟ้าครูเรียมในเราบอกว่าอยู่ที่บ้านหมู่
บ้านจะเป็นพระราชาพระราชินีก็คือเป็นวัง
นะชายก็ถึงบ้านใหญ่ๆว่างใหญ่ๆใช่แล้วก็
ไทยจะมีในก็เห็นวังนะแล้วก็เห็นธงขึ้น
เป็นธงสีแดงค่ะครูเลี่ยม
ทองสีแดงหมายความว่าก็หมายความว่าลูกชาย
12 คนต้องตาย
เบญจมินทร์ก็เลยเห็นปุ๊บก็เลยลงมาแล้วก็
บอกพี่ชายว่าทุกคนธงเป็นสีแดง
พี่ชายทุกคนก็เลยรู้สึกยิ่งโกรธแล้วก็ไม่
โหอ่ะก็เข้าไปในวังไหมคะเป็ดข้า
ไม่หักหนูอร่อยไม่ได้ใช่พี่ชายก็เลยคุย
กันว่าโอเคถ้าเกิดเราเจอผู้หญิงคนไหนเรา
จะ 5 ผู้หญิงคนนั้นเราไม่ชอบผู้หญิง
สาวตัวเองนะคนอื่นไม่ได้ทำอะไรให้เลยนะก็
จะฆ่าต้องฆ่าเพราะว่าโกรธไงใช่ไหม
หาเจ้าชายแบบเดินผ่านบ้านเรามาทำยังไง
เนี่ยเขาก็จะฆ่าเราค่ะเพราะเขาไม่ชอบผู้
หญิงท้องสู้ค่ะเราต้องแบบสิ
ใช่อ่ะต่อสู้เพื่อคุณชายหน่อยคิดว่าเจ้า
ชาย 12 คนเนี่ยจะตายเพราะว่าผู้หญิงอ่ะ
อ้าวน้องสาวใช่ไหมพอมีน้องสาวเนี่ยตัวเอง
ก็ต้องตายก็เลยคิดไม่ชอบผู้หญิงก็คุยกัน
ไว้แล้วก็เหมือนสัญญากันนะสัญญาว่าถ้าเจอ
ผู้หญิงที่ไหนเราจะฆ่าทิ้งข้าข้าพี่หมด
อะไรอีก 3 ว่าเขาก็อยู่ไหนนี่แหละเขาเข้า
ไปในหมู่บ้านแล้วไปฆ่าคนไหมไม่ห้ามๆเจ้า
ชายในแค่หนีหนีเข้าไปในป่าแล้วก็ไปเจอ
บ้านเล็กๆบ้านเล็กๆที่หนึ่งนะก็เลยเข้าไป
อยู่ในบ้านด้วยกัน 12 คนและก็คุยกันไว้
ว่า 12 คนเนี่ย
จะให้เบญจมินทร์น้องชายคนเล็กที่สุดหนึ่ง
น้องชายคนเล็กที่สุดเลยเบญจมินทร์เนี่ย
ไม่แข็งแรงแต่ก็ยังเด็กนะคะก็เลยให้
เบญจมินทร์ทำความสะอาดบ้านทำความสะอาด
บ้านแล้วก็ดูแลบ้าน
ได้พี่ชาย 11 คนก็เลยจะออกไปแล้วก็ไปหา
หมูหาไก่เราบอกว่าไปหาสัตว์มานะคะเพราะ
ต้องกินใช่ไหมล่ะเงินก็ขอและ
เสื้อ
ก็อยู่ด้วยกันก็จบไงก็เจ้าชาย 12 คนก็ไม่
ตายยังไม่จบค่ะครูเรียมเพราะว่าเขาก็อยู่
ด้วยกันเนี่ยที่ก็ที่บ้านเล็กๆในป่านะคะ
อยู่ด้วยกันมาประมาณ
10 ปี
หนูนานานาๆนั้นมากเลยจน
เวลาก็ผ่านไป 10 ปีแล้วเนาะ 10 ปีเลยนะคะ
เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยที่เป็นน้องสาวของเจ้าชาย
เนาะเจ้าหญิงก็โตขึ้นมีอายุ 10 ขวบนี้ก็
หญิงแล้วก็มีหน้าตาที่สวยใช่ไหมสวยน่ารัก
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงก็เป็นคนดีนะคะเค้าบอกว่าเจ้าหญิง
เป็นคนดีหน้าตาสวยแล้วก็ใจดีมาก
วันนึงเนี่ย
ในวางเนี่ยก็จะมีคุณซักผ้าใช่ไหมเวลาเรา
ใส่เสื้อเราก็ต้องซักนะคะนักเรียนซักซัก
ซักแต่เจ้าหญิงจะไม่ซักผ้าเองเนาะเขาจะมี
คนเจ้าหญิงอ่ะทำไมไม่ซักผ้าเองเป็นเจ้า
หญิงในโคเรียมไม่ซักผ้าเอง
อ้าวแล้วทำไงคะไม่เคยมีคุณมีคนซักให้หาคน
เลี้ยงอยู่คนทรัพย์จริงจังเลยแม่เจ้าหญิง
ก็เลยเดินไปเห็นเป็นเสื้อของผู้ชาย
เสื้อเชิ้ตนะเป็นเชื้อของผู้ชายมีอยู่ 12
ตัว
สิ่งก็เลยถามว่าเสื้ออันนี้ของใครคงไม่
ใช่ของพ่อมั้งเพราะว่าเสื้อเล็กๆเอาเลย
ค่ะคุณแม่นะคะเพื่อที่นี่ก็เลยบอกว่าจริง
ๆแล้วเนี่ยเสื้อเนี่ยเป็นของพี่ชายนะลูก
นะมีพี่ชาย 12 คน
หือนะพบจริงหรอคะพี่ชายหายไปไหนใช่แล้ว
พี่ชายหายไปไหนคุณแม่ก็เล่าให้ฟังนะคะคุณ
แม่ก็เลยบอกว่าเนี่ยพี่ชายตอนนี้อยู่ใน
ป่าหนีเพราะว่าจะได้ไม่ตายทำไมกันเล่าเรา
เราเราเล่าให้เจ้าหญิงฟังแล้วก็บอกว่าตอน
นี้เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าเจ้าหญิงเออเจ้าชายอยู่
ที่ไหนไม่รู้ว่าเจ้าควายอยู่ที่ไหนเจ้า
หญิงก็เลยบอกว่าแม่ไม่เป็นไรนะเดี๋ยวลูก
จะไปตามหาพี่ชาย
พี่ชายอยู่ที่ไหนไม่ใช่อยู่ไหนเอาเราไม่
ให้ออกมาในคะฟ้าแม่ก็โอเคค่ะแม่บอกว่า
โอเคถ้างั้นลูกก็ไปตามหาพี่ชายเรานั่น
แหละพ่อเขาไม่ว่าเหรออะเราฉันรู้คิดว่า
พ่อไม่รู้ไงมึงเอาไม่รู้นะฮะอาชาใจร้าย
เรื่องเป็นพระราชาเลยนะเนี่ยไม่เรื่องทุก
อย่างเกิดขึ้นเพราะว่าราชาใจร้ายนะคะเจ้า
หญิงแล้วก็เอาเสื้อทั้งหมดของพี่ชายเนาะ
เสื้อเสื้อ 12 ตัวเนี่ยเอาไปด้วยใส่
กระเป๋า
ทำไมอ้ะเค้าใช้วิธีแบบให้หมาดมกลิ่นให้
แบบหมาดมนั่นน่ะสิให้ดูวิ่งกฎหมายนะวัน
นี้รับหมดเป็นหมาใช่ป่ะนี่มันว่าหา
เดินเข้าไปในป่าภูเลียมเจ้าหญิงก็เดิน
เข้าไปในป่าเลยนะเดินๆ
แล้วเรียนรู้ไหมคะว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
ไม่รู้กับอะไรขึ้นเขาฟ้าหมดเวลา
เจ้าหญิงหมดเวลาแล้วเราหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะคุณ
พี่และก็หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วเราว่าถ้า
เราไม่จบใช่ไหมคะยังไม่จบค่ะคุณเรียน
เนื้อเรื่องยังมีต่ออีกนะคะเพราะว่าเจ้า
หญิงไปหาพี่ชายใช่ไหม
ก็เลย
หมดเวลานั้นจะเป็นยังไงอ่ะเจ้าชายทั้งสิบ
สองคนเจอผู้หญิงแล้วก็ต้องฆ่านี้ใช่ไหมคะ
ฟ้าให้เราเจ้าหญิงจะตายมั้ย
ไม่รู้เลยเอาเวลาหมดเดี๋ยวรอเจอกันตรงที่
นิดน่าใช้หาเราจะต้องเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะ
คะนักเรียนนักเรียนอยากฟังมาเรียนก็ดู
วีดีโอหน้าด้วยนะจะได้รู้ว่าตอนจบเป็นยัง
ไงอะไรแล้วค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อน
แล้วค่ะคือฟ้าได้ครับทุเรียนนั้นเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะให้ราคาสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายน